these questions come up a lot you know
and you so there's articles written
about this like what are the three most
important characteristics of a leader
Vision Charisma you know and I've met
some wonderful fantastic leaders who are
not big Steve Jobs Visionaries sure you
know and I've met some amazing leaders
who don't seem to have sort of that
bounce off-the-wall Charisma you know
they sort of The Quiet One sitting in
the corner um I am comfortable saying
however that great leaders the best
leaders I've ever met they will have
courage um leadership is extremely
difficult um sometimes
um it's thankless it's lonely when
things go right you have to give away
the credit when things go wrong you have
to take all the responsibility well that
sucks um uh and it's sometimes the the
gains are sometimes not immediate um and
it takes tremendous amount of Courage uh
to lead um what's more you know we talk
about integrity I think Integrity takes
courage you know to speak truth to power
to do the right thing in the face of
overwhelming pressure to do the opposite
um all of these things take courage
which I think begs the question then
where does courage come from um uh I
don't believe that courage is an
internal fortitude where you dig down
deep and find the courage I think
courage is external um it's like you
know a world famous trapeze artist has
the courage to try a brand new death
defying act for the first time with a
net they wouldn't try it without the net
it's the net that gave them the courage
and I think so too is it for human
beings that the quality of our
relationships um give us courage you
talk to folks in uniform who do heroic
things they'll never say it was for God
or country it was for the person to the
left or the person to the right it was
the quality of the relationships and so
for us to build courage what we have to
do is invest in relationships because
when you're facing a very difficult
situation an ethical challenge a work
challenge whatever it is all we need is
one person in our Lives who says I've
got your back I believe in you you have
to do this it's the right thing to do
and if everything goes sideways don't
worry I'll be there with you I mean even
just talking about it you feel like you
have Renewed Energy and so if you have
one person in your life who can provide
that for you at work or at home um
you'll be amazed the amount of Courage
you have to do the right thing and to
lead